Jordan B.
Peterson
in your lectures,
you used the term postmodernism interchangeably with cultural Marxism,
nihilism and moral relativism.
I wonder if you've considered or heard alternative beliefs at the term
postmodernism is not necessary,
is necessarily always congruent on a one to one scale with these other terms and
in some limited circumstances is positive.
Specifically the idea that wouldn't,
you'd use the term postmodernism to vilify is by some others referred to as
pseudo modernism where as some would call what you endorsed to not be modernism
but in fact Metta modernism post millennialism or post postmodernism,
which unfortunately has a terrible name.
And then I have very brief just definitions of those words.
If you need me to know,
as I said tonight,
you have to give the devil his due
and so we'll do that.
So yes,
there was a very large number of ways of interpreting the world.
There's no doubt about that.
Um,
yes.
People use biased interpretive lenses to as means of interpreting the world to
put their own
okay.
Priorities forward without necessarily knowing that they're doing so and that
that can corrupt them.
And Society.
Psychoanalysts figured that out way before the postmodernist.
So they don't get any credit for that.
Like really none.
MMM.
So it's useful to keep those things in mind.
It's when they're put,
but it's when they're put forward is absolute truth that disturbs me.
It's like,
yes,
people are probably racist.
They might even be implicitly racist,
although we don't know what that means and we don't know how it's related to
their explicit behavior.
And we can't separate it from in group preference or necessarily from reaction
to novelty.
So it's a tricky business.
You know,
and we don't know how to separate stereotypical racial perceptions from
perceptual heuristics.
We don't know how to do that.
Cause you're always oversimplifying the world because you're not smart enough to
live in the world as it is.
You have to oversimplify it.
So yes,
there are times when postmodernism is useful,
are used it quite usefully tonight to deconstruct postmodernism.
In fact.
So,
but,
but wait,
it's when it's turned into an absolute,
especially a moral absolute that it,
and when it aligns itself with Marxism,
it's like,
sorry guys.
No,
you don't like grand narratives.
You don't get to go there while that's where you,
that isn't where you went,
that's where you came from.
You never,
you never left there.